düsseldorf verfügt über 1.250 taxi
konzessionen
hinzu kommen die alternativen
mobilitätsdienstleister wie über die
auch personenbeförderung anbieten
ich mach das auch das deutsche
unternehmen hinter dem daimler und bmw
stehen wie baywa werden mittels app
personenfahrten vermittelt oder clever
shuttle eine art bestell sammeltaxi ihr
buch der kunde via app einen sitzplatz
und wird dann in kleinbussen zusammen
mit anderen befördert
insgesamt gibt es allein in düsseldorf
mittlerweile 2000 autos die personen von
a nach b bringen
die neue mobilitätsanbieter um uba sind
bisher gesetzlich nie berücksichtigt
worden
sie sind mit ausnahmegenehmigungen
gefahren und mit regeln die sich
erheblich von denen der taxis
unterschieden
dieser wildwuchs hat für heftige
konflikte im kampf um deutschlands
straßen gesorgt die bisher die gerichte
geklärt haben mit dem neuen gesetz
versucht das bundesverkehrsministerium
dem jetzt entgegenzuwirken taxibetriebe
kritisieren dass die bereits bestehenden
ungleichheiten damit nur noch stärker
werden zum beispiel die tarife pro fahrt
für taxis festgelegt von den kommunen
huber & co können dagegen den preis nach
angebot und nachfrage frei gestalten wie
weit liegen die angebote auseinander
ich mache den test die selbe strecke vom
medienhafen in die innenstadt mit dem
taxi in und mit dem u boot zurück zuerst
rufe ich mir ganz klassisch ein taxi und
das geht mittlerweile ebenfalls bequem
per app ich sehe ganz genau wie viele
taxis rom oben stehen wie lange die zu
mir brauchen und ich bekomme auch
angezeigt eine ungefähre zeit wie die
strecke dauert wir wollen zur
immermannstraße fahren in den
düsseldorfer innenstadt nach
hauptbahnhof das dauert von hier etwas
mehr als zehn minuten und kostet
irgendetwas zwischen 14 und 18 euro
dann bestelle ich jetzt mal das taxi
keine zwei minuten später ist es da der
fahrer erzählt mir dass er drei stunden
auf diesen auftrag warten musste bei so
vielen taxis haben sie zwei lange
standzeiten durch uwe aber seien die
wartezeiten noch länger
in der düsseldorfer innenstadt komme ich
zwar schneller an muss aber auch mehr
bezahlen als angekündigt so das hat sehr
gut geklappt keine zehn minuten hat die
fahrt gedauert
20 euro habe ich dafür bezahlt jetzt bin
ich gespannt wie es mit dem überlassen
kuba ist ein technologieunternehmen aus
den usa und erobert zurzeit die welt
nutzen um die 100 millionen kunden in
mehr als 700 städten die über apps das
sind 14 millionen fahrten pro tag allein
in london gibt es mittlerweile mehr als
40.000 überfahren und fahrer und nur
noch rund 15.000 taxifahrer bekommt in
der regel 25 prozent provision vom
fahrpreis
das unternehmen sieht sich nur als
vermittler zwischen fahrer und fahrgast
nicht als beförderungsunternehmen obwohl
huber mit seiner app über preis und
strecke bestimmt ist trägt die
fahrtstrecke vorgegeben
die muss der fahrer auch einmal dann
bestelle ich denn jetzt mal abholung
bestätigung
das kostet 99 54
also weniger als die hälfte mit dem taxi
direkt gegenüber wartet das uba auf mich
der preis ist vorab festgelegt die
strecke ebenfalls die fahrer verfügen
über einen personenbeförderungsschein
und arbeiten für lokale sub unternehmer
über selbst besitzt keine eigenen
fahrzeuge
das fazit nach unserem test die
überfahrt hat nur die hälfte von der
taxifahrt kostet neun euro 57 statt 20
euro mit trinke beim taxifahrer beide
sind souverän gefahren da kann man nicht
meckern aber der preis ist natürlich
hier schon ein gewaltiger
wettbewerbsvorteil für über wie geht das
mit den günstigen preisen kommt da noch
was bei den fahrerinnen und fahrern an
wir wollen darüber mit ihnen sprechen
und fragen am betriebssitz des
unternehmers von huber in düsseldorf
nach
dazu sagen ich bin der tasse ich komme
vom zdf in der sendung zoom und wir
wollten mal mit über fahrern ins
gespräch kommen er ist ein beifahrer ich
weiß nicht aber hat einen deswegen steht
das ist ja nur jemand mit dem man
sprechen können wenn sie jetzt jemanden
sehen mit dem autor dann können sie
gerne mit den sprechen kämpfen jetzt
sind wir zwei kollegen freundlich werden
wir ein anderer fahrer verwiesen
der 24 jährige josef ist bereit mit uns
zu reden ihnen fragen wir auch die das
mit der bezahlung läuft aber sie haben
einen anderen job ja ja ich hab auch
noch weil ich mache das aber kollegen
vor mir sind die manche sind seit
eineinhalb jahre zwei jahre hier
sie sagen ja frühjahr hat gut
funktioniert aber das bisschen
schlechter geworden
was wäre denn ohne den minijob ohne
dieses pizza aus fahren wir dann wer
hier noch geld in der kasse vielleicht
wissen schlecht mich also ehrlich gesagt
und dann ist auch noch corona aber auch
ohne pandemiepläne josef mit
umsatzbeteiligung kaum auf den
gesetzlichen mindestlohn
mit zwei jobs hält er sich irgendwie
über wasser wie viele als fahrer des uba
dienstleisters verdient mag er nicht
verraten
allerdings wird deutlich dass er keinen
festen stundenlohn erhält den wünscht er
sich aber
schaffen sie das mit einer
umsatzbeteiligung
ich glaube nicht so weitergeht diese
zeit glaube nicht dass es da besser dass
durch die stunde lang mit einer solchen
umsatzbeteiligung ist der gesetzliche
mindestlohn nicht garantiert dieser
liegt zurzeit bei 9 euro 50 pro stunde
bedeutet also preisdumping hier auch
lohndumping weil übers zum unternehmer
nach umsatzbeteiligung und nicht nach
mindestlohn bezahlen
um diese frage zu beantworten sind wir
mit maren burkhard verabredet die
sozialwissenschaftlerin untersucht
verschiedene digitale plattformen in
bezug auf ihre fairness der
arbeitsbedingungen
dazu gehören faire arbeit faire
arbeitsbedingungen faire verträge für
das management und fairen mitsprache für
diese fünf bereiche konnten insgesamt
zehn punkte erzielt werden huber ist auf
dem letzten platz gelandet mit einem von
zehn möglichen punkten alle anderen
digital plattformen haben deutlich mehr
erzielen können aber ist mit der wertung
allerdings nicht einverstanden und sagt
sie sah ihn nur vermittler denn die
fahrer würden schließlich für
subunternehmer tätig wir sehen bei über
eine runter vergabepraxis wenn diese
digitale plattform für sich in anspruch
nimmt
wir sind sozusagen wir haben einen
subunternehmer den wir beauftragen und
dieser so unternehmer beantragt wieder
weitere subunternehmer und
subunternehmer und sub unternehmer dann
ist es rechtlich gesehen
von mir aus auf einer sicheren seite
indem sie sagen na ja unsere unsere
verantwortung ist hier begrenzt die
frage ist ist das dann immer noch fair
den arbeiten dem gegenüber was werden
andere vorschläge und sage ich mal die
bei schlechter abgeschnitten haben wie
zum beispiel über nach vorne zu bringen
dass die regeln eingehalten
dann könnte man natürlich auch sagen als
über ist es uns ganz wichtig faire
arbeitsbedingungen zu schaffen deshalb
machen wir eine richtlinie für unsere
unternehmen und sagen wir wollen auf
jeden fall dass das und dass sich
hergestellt wird
ansonsten können wir nicht mit euch in
verhandlungen treten wäre aus sicht der
plattform eine möglichkeit der
interaktion mit subunternehmern
wenn man das nicht macht muss man sich
halt sein auch dieser wertung stellen
anfang märz hat der bundestag ein neues
gesetz beschlossen die darin
festgelegten regeln sollen einen fairen
wettbewerb zwischen taxis und taxi
ähnlichen anbietern sicherstellen
wir sind mit dem parlamentarischen
staatssekretär steffen bilger aus dem
bundesverkehrsministerium verabredet und
wollen wissen welche vision das
ministerium mit dem neuen gesetz
verbindet wir setzen darauf dass wir
diese form des
personenbeförderungsgesetzes diese neue
mobilitätsangebote ermöglichen und wir
wissen ja auch alle die menschen in
unserem land die wollen diese neuen
angebote auch nutzen es gibt jetzt schon
sehr viele die mit diesen neuen
mobilitätsanbieter unterwegs sind es
gibt auch sehr viele die weiter mit dem
taxi fahren wollen und da geht es für
uns einfach darum mobilität zu
ermöglichen so dass es für die
verbraucher
natürlich auch kostengünstig ist warum
sind da keine regelungen eingezogen
worden waren es ist ja bekannt aus der
plattform ökonomie dass die bezahlung
dort sehr schlecht ist und die
taxiinnung sagt lohndumping führt eben
auch zu preisdumping und deshalb können
die fahrten so preiswert angeboten
werden seitens über und co
dann kommt natürlich auch darauf an dass
die zuständigen behörden sicherstellen
dass alle regeln eingehalten werden also
das günstige preise nicht so erzielt
werden indem man sozialstandards
weiteren fahrern nicht einhält oder
andere regeln missachtet verpflichtende
sozialstandards hat das neue gesetz
allerdings nicht vorgesehen und auch
verbindliche kontrollen ob der
gesetzliche mindestlohn bezahlt wird
finden sich
nicht dazu kommt dass taxis zu einem
festen kilometer tarif fahren den städte
und kommunen bestimmen taxis müssen 24
stunden sieben tage die woche verfügbar
sein und jede fahrt annehmen um
flächendeckende mobilität in der stadt
und auf dem land zu gewährleisten
so ist es schon lange gesetzlich
festgeschrieben
ein klarer wettbewerbsnachteil gegenüber
den neuen mobilitäts anbietern wie über
denn bei denen bestimmen angebot und
nachfrage den preis
zudem müssen die fahrzeuge nicht immer
verfügbar sein und schon gar nicht jede
fahrt annehmen
das ändert sich auch nicht mit dem neuen
gesetz
das kritisiert der taxi bundesverband
der die interessen von 250.000
taxifahren vertritt für geschäftsführer
michael oppermann eine herausfordernde
situation gegen einen globalen tech
giganten anzutreten
der nach ganz anderen regeln agiert als
taxis das ist natürlich eine frage die
die politik zu entscheiden hat ja wie
dieser konflikt ausgeht
die taxifahrerin und taxifahrer haben
ein recht auf anständige jobs auch
vernünftige arbeitsbedingungen dafür
kämpfen wir auch mit nachdruck auch mit
rückhalt von der straße das haben wir
auch 2009 10 bei zahlreichen protesten
gesehen durch oberst markteintritt
verklagt die branche nach eigenen
aussagen fast ein drittel umsatzrückgang
im schnitt mache ein taxi nur noch 25
euro umsatz pro stunde von dem alles
bezahlt werden müssen um die 1000
taxiunternehmen haben deswegen allein
2009 10 dichtgemacht 2020 rechnet der
verband auch durch bewohner mit einer
zusätzlichen verschärfung dieser
situation durch die neue konkurrenz sei
die versorgung mit flächendeckender
mobilität in gefahr und sagt auch immer
konkurrenz belebt das geschäft
warum ist das jetzt nicht der fall
müssen sich nicht die taxibranche ein
bisschen frischer digitaler innovativer
aufstellen so wie es aber tut ist für
mich in sehr guten punkt wir wollen
qualitätswettbewerb stadt preisdumping
übersetzt klar auf dumpingpreise wenn so
lange vorne links im fahrzeug einer
sitzt die einfache formel
dumpingpreise gibt es nur zu
dumpinglöhnen und da machen wir nicht
mit
wenn über diesen weg gehen will ist
alles weg unserer ist es nicht und
unsere überzeugung ist es sollte auch
nicht der weg des deutschen sozial- und
rechtsstaat
das wollen wir auch von über wissen wie
sie dieses etwaige lohndumping ihrer
dienstleister sehen
in berlin treffen wir den general
manager deutschland des unternehmens
christoph winkler und fragen ihn nach
seiner einschätzung zur
umsatzbeteiligung der fahrer dann müsste
also der fahrer jede stunde sage ich mal
so zweieinhalb bis dreieinhalb fahrten
haben um war ich mal den mindestlohn
dann dann auch zu bekommen und das kann
man ja sicherlich nicht immer
gewährleisten ist auf jeden fall möglich
ordentlich zu verdienen sowohl für die
unternehmen als auch für die fahrer
und ja das ist wenn man die das feedback
das ich bekomme ist aber natürlich auch
so dass viele fahrer mit verschiedensten
anbietern zusammenarbeiten also der
typische unternehmer ist ich hab'
blumenstrauß an stammkunden ich lasse
mir von verschiedenen app vermittlern
was vermitteln und daraus als das sollte
man eben eine mischkalkulation und die
die ich kenne verdienen eben ordentlich
und kommen damit gut über die runden
aber alleine reicht also um gut über die
runden zu kommen
das wollen wir genauer wir fragen mehmet
yilmaz
er hat als über fahrer gearbeitet zwei
fahrten pro stunde in der regel wie er
selber sagt deshalb sei er wieder als
taxifahrer aktiv valletta mindestlohn
bekommt bei dem subunternehmen oberst
sei er nur nach umsatz bezahlt worden
ich war ein sehr gutes fahrrad 4,5 und
90 das ist vom 5 prof
ein fahrer krieg präsenz das heißt
insgesamt mensch technisch 100 euro
umsatz mache 30 euro höchstens also
zwischen 20 30 euro verdiene nicht warum
sind sie überhaupt den schritt gegangen
über fahrer zu werden weil sie haben ja
erzählt sie werden vorher taxifahrer
gewesen ich wollte das problem etwas
bedeutet ich wollte selber sehen und ich
habe das gesehen dass es die sagen uns
ab und natürlich das ist harte arbeit 10
12 stunden unterwegs und ganz wenig
verdienen dass es unfair dass es richtig
nicht in ordnung
einige länder reagieren bereits so hat
zum beispiel in großbritannien vor
kurzem das oberste gericht entschieden
dass obama
und fahrer fest angestellt sein müssen
dieses urteil betrifft 65.000 fahrer und
wird sich dort massiv auf das
geschäftsmodell huber aus
anderes beispiel in österreich gelten
seit diesem jahr für alle anbieter
dieselben spielregeln dafür sorgt ein
entsprechendes gesetz taxis und alle
anderen mobilitätsanbieter sind damit
gleichgestellt
damit soll ein fairer wettbewerb
zwischen den anbietern garantiert werden
wir fragen beim
bundesverkehrsministerium nach ob eine
klare angleichung der regeln für taxis
und deren konkurrenz nicht der bessere
weg gewesen wäre zum beispiel nach dem
vorbild österreichs
unser ziel heißt auch nicht ein gesetz
so zu machen dass wir mobilitätsangebote
verhindert sondern auftrag aus dem
koalitionsvertrag lautet der neue
mobilitätsangebote ermöglichen aber
gleichzeitig eben auch das was sich
bewährt hat und wir brauchen die taxis
auch weiter in den städten vor allem
auch in den ländlichen räumen aber auch
zu erhalten und deswegen gibt es ja auch
bestimmte regelungen die die taxis
privilegieren weil sie zum beispiel dass
ich an der straße ein taxi anhalten kann
einsteigen kann das ist ein beleg dass
weiterhin die taxis haben
den taxifahrern geht das aber nicht weit
genug
sie fühlen sich von der politik alleine
gelassen einen von ihnen treffen mehr
ingo chronist enttäuscht dass aller
protest gegen das neue gesetz nichts
genutzt habe wir sind ja die tariflich
gebunden und opa kann das kann das kann
die tarife oder den den preis frei
bestimmen
und deswegen ist das keine belebung des
geschäfts was haben sie für erlebnisse
gehabt mit der neuen konkurrenz über
hier auf den straßen düsseldorfs ja man
kommt sich immer mal wieder in die quere
aber was soll man machen das sind ja
auch nur fahrer kann im endeffekt ja
auch nichts dafür wir wollen ja auch
hier geld verdienen
gleichzeitig aber fürchtete er um seine
berufliche existenz denn taxifahrer
können fahrpreise nicht selber festlegen
das macht weiterhin die stadt düsseldorf
für eine 1250 taxis deshalb sei aber
meist preiswerter als er weil sie nicht
diesen tarifen unterliegen
ein kampf den er nicht gewinnen kann und
der zu konflikten zwischen taxifahrern
führt
sie haben da auch schon mal mitunter
kandidaten die steigenden und versuchen
vor ingo krone taucht ein über auf er
hat das gefühl dass es neue fahrgäste
auf sammeln will und deshalb ziellos
seine runden dreht diese art von
kundenfang ist ein großer aufreger
weil über und co das gar nicht dürfen
wir bleiben stehen da ist kommt da raus
das macht er fotos von uns denn so
mein video läuft auch mit
[Musik]
das kann ich für sie tun was was machst
du denn bei mir was ist das video
überhaupt das ist immer mehr
weiterregieren
so erfüllt sich adaptieren ich habe auch
alles auf video
wer möchte mich anzeigen aber deswegen
würden sie denn sagen weil ich ihn
verfolge oder keine ahnung
der öffentliche verkehrsraum hier dieser
konflikt auf der straße spielt schon
seit über in deutschland gestartet ist
der vorwurf der taxiunternehmer die ober
fahrerinnen und fahrer können direkt
über die app war aufträge annehmen
doch in dem fall greift noch eine
gesetzliche regelung aus den 80er jahren
die ihnen das verbietet der auftrag muss
immer über den betriebssitz an die
fahrer vermittelt werden
dorthin müssen sie nach jedem auftragen
zurückkehren denn es gilt für huber & co
eine sogenannte rückkehr pflicht doch
die wenigsten fahrer sollen sich daran
halten
deshalb haben die taxifahrer geklagt und
mit erfolg unter anderem das landgericht
düsseldorf hat in einem verfahren über
und seine app verboten in der begründung
des gerichts vom april 2020 heißt es
außerdem besteht für den fahrer in der
app die möglichkeit den auftrag über die
app anzunehmen
somit nimmt die beklagte verstöße ihrer
partner und deren fahrer bewusst in kauf
verstöße gegen dieses fahrverbot in
düsseldorf könnten jetzt bis zu 250.000
euro strafe kosten
das unternehmen hat berufung gegen das
urteil eingelegt es ist somit noch nicht
rechtskräftig
die beibehaltung der rückkehr pflicht
und die diversen gerichtsurteile die
sich in berufungen befinden erschweren
das uba geschäftsmodell in deutschland
zunehmend erklärt deutschland chef
christoph eichler
wir nehmen das unheimlich ernst und das
thema rückt pflicht gehört zu den
rechtsrahmen insofern müssen wir das
auch respektieren wir haben sogar unsere
app massiv umgebaut ist es mittlerweile
so technisch wir stellen sicher dass nur
fahrten an fahrzeuge vermittelt werden
die sich auf der rückkehr zum
betriebssitz befinden
die günstigen preise die über & co im
gegensatz zu den taxis anbieten können
sorgen auf jeden fall weiterhin für
erhebliche konflikte auf deutschlands
straßen
und schwächen für die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher die mobilität weil
dadurch immer mehr taxis aufgeben müssen
die frage wollen sie immer nur den
billigsten preis oder wollen sie auch
sicher transportiert werden wollen sie
wollen sie einen eine eine
fachgesellschaft in anspruch nehmen von
der sie wissen dass sie sozusagen dass
das geld auch bei dem fahrer ankommt und
nicht in der kaskade von subunternehmern
verschwindet und derjenige der sie da
herum fährt vielleicht ganz wenig davon
sieht denn letztendlich und das ist auch
etwas was man mit den digitalen medien
sie sind das die die endverbraucher das
sind wir die kunden die die
entscheidungsmacht haben
denn ende des monats das neue gesetz
auch im bundesrat eine mehrheit findet
bedeutet dass es gibt ganz offiziell
unterschiedliche bedingungen für
dieselbe dienstleistung
das ist nicht die lösung für einen
fairen wettbewerb zwischen taxi und tuba
und co
[Musik]